[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
sentencing for a leader of a so-called
sex cult ranieri
was truly a modern-day svengali
do prosecutors get their wish of life in
prison or something less
plus
you're a murderer our cameras capture a
grieving family
shouting down the defendant they say
killed a young woman
near cincinnati and a baseball player
accused of using a bat as a murder
weapon
wielding the instrument of his
profession
as an instrument of death he blames the
state for letting him out of a mental
hospital
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
america has a new supreme court justice
amy coney barrett was sworn in at the
white house by
justice clarence thomas and took a
judicial oath before chief justice john
roberts
barron now begins her lifetime
appointment to the court and is able to
participate fully in the cases and
controversies before it
the senate vote to confirm barrett was
52-48
one of the closest in modern history the
leader of a self-help group which
prosecutors say was also a sex
cult is learning his sentence terry
austin has that report for us now terry
erin this is the case of nexium leader
keith reneer a federal jury found him
guilty of
every single count prosecutors allege
renee is among
several nexium members to be charged a
judge sentenced him to
120 years in prison others in the group
included actress alison mack and
seagram's liquor heir
claire rothman brothman agreed to
forfeit
6 million dollars as part of a guilty
plea which resulted in a sentence of
6 years and nine months mack pleaded
guilty but has not been sentenced here's
how prosecutors summed up the case
when the jury convicted reneer
ranieri who portrayed himself
as a savant and a genius
was in fact a master manipulator
a con man and the crime boss
of a cult-like organization involved in
sex
trafficking child pornography
extortion compelled abortions
branding degradation
and humiliation his crimes and the
crimes of his co-conspirators
ruined marriages careers
fortunes and lives
victims addressed the judge one said
rene starved her to look like a
12-year-old
and raped her thanks for the update in
that case terry
another accuser has stepped forward to
make claims against now convicted sex
offender harvey weinstein
the new york daily news reports that a
61 year old woman
filed a complaint with the new york
police department saying that weinstein
forced her to perform oral sex at a
nightclub in manhattan in the 1990s
weinstein is serving a 23-year sentence
in new york but
faces an increasing list of charges in
california weinstein denies that
he committed any crimes ohio's top cop
has a warning for anyone looking to post
bail for a lawyer accused of selling
women for sex
we first told you about michael moran on
our last broadcast
he faces 18 felony counts of
racketeering and promoting prostitution
moran is accused of giving some of his
clients drugs and trafficking them
the charges involve claims from six
women over 15 years
ohio attorney general dave yost says
moran complained in court that he was
poor and couldn't post his three hundred
thousand dollar bond
one of the reasons that it's so awful is
because this is a man who
society gave trust to he's professional
he's a public official or a former
public official
he's somebody with specialized knowledge
he can go places and knows things
that other people can't go and don't
know
and he used that to
sell human beings uh i i just can't
think of a worse
abuse of trust if you have the money and
you have it in your heart to help this
man
and you want to give him the post of
bond for him
that's one thing but if what you're
doing is
buying his silence then
that's a additional that's another crime
and a furtherance of the racketeering
enterprise
so here's my message to anybody that's
thinking about
posting bond from michael mirren you
better make sure you're clean
because we're going to be watching the
ag says there are
more survivors out there who have
information about moran the attorney
general's office wants to hear from them
an ohio man making an appearance in
court on charges he dumped a missing
teenage girl's body
more than 10 years ago a trial date was
expected to be set for
jacob bumpus just outside cincinnati but
a date wasn't set because his lawyers
are still reviewing evidence
bumpus is charged with tampering with
evidence and abuse of a corpse in
connection with the disappearance of
paige johnson in september 2010.
johnson left her mother's home in
northern kentucky to go out with friends
and was never seen again her mother said
bumpus admitted to giving paige who was
17
alcohol that night she disappeared
prosecutors say
pings from bumpus's cell phone the night
johnson disappeared put him
in the area where her skeletal remains
were found earlier
this year an area nearby had been
searched several times
it's upsetting but somewhat to be
expected
i mean we've never been through a trial
before but we watch tv so
you know we know that this is going to
take time it's just
um kind of like a punch in the gut every
time he gets to walk out
and just be free and live his life
it's just seems so unfair
because she doesn't get to ever walk
this earth again
we just want him to tell the truth i was
saying that in there with
scott o'reilly the prosecutor i don't
care about any jail time if he would
just
tell the truth tell us what happened
a sheriff's deputy escorted bumpus out
of the courthouse as paige johnson's
friends and family yelled at him and
held signs calling for justice for paige
the defendant is due back in court in
december terry brian let's jump in now
here so terry
tampering with evidence and abuse of a
corpse the family is asking for higher
charges they want murder charges here
but i'm hearing one of the issues is
that there's no cause of death all that
was left of the victim was her bones
does that mean the defendant can't be
charged with anything higher
up the criminal ladder not necessarily
aaron because listen
it's always easier to prosecute a
defendant if you have the body
and if you know what the cause and
manner of death is
but actually there have been plenty of
instances where there has been a
conviction
with only circumstantial or forensic
evidence i mean you remember i think
everyone probably does the jeffrey
dahmer case
he pulverized some of his victims and
scattered all of their remains across
the
forest and so it is possible he was
convicted and
he was convicted only on the forensic
and circumstantial evidence so
it's possible it's easier with the body
and the cause but it is possible
so brian have to ask about the defense
strategy here abuse of a corpse is a
fifth degree felony in ohio that's less
than a year in jail tampering with
evidence is a third degree felony that's
punishable by up to three years
what should the defense be doing right
now at this point they should be
collecting evidence and they should be
staying as quiet as possible right now
what we're seeing is that the pinging
of a cell phone puts the defendant in
close proximity to the to the victims
bodies or remains
and outside of that there's not much
connecting him to this case
so you really want to wait see and
investigate to build a case to hopefully
prove or try to show some reasonable
doubt here
and that will potentially be a tall
order depending on how the rest of the
evidence shakes out brian and terry
appreciate the input there still ahead
here on law and crime daily the governor
of california making
a legal argument that the death penalty
is racist
plus the family of a man who died in
police custody takes another step
they hope will lead to justice more on
those cases and others when law on crime
daily returns
we have several civil rights cases to
report including a case
involving the death of javier ambler in
police custody brian buckmeyer is here
with more
on a number of cases for us brian thanks
erin civil rights attorney benjamin
crump is suing williamson county texas
over ambler's death now authorities say
ambler
didn't dim his headlights for oncoming
traffic
so they chased him tased him and
ultimately killed him
a crew from the former a e network show
live pd
was riding along with the police crump
says the police chases
and violent encounters doubled in
williamson county
because of its contract with live pd now
tweeting about the case krump says
williamson county texas deputies
cared more about dramatic content on
live pd than javier ambrose life
cops must set priorities for citizen
safety over everything and we will not
stop
until we get justice and officers are
held accountable for ethical reasons we
must disclose that any owns a portion of
the law and crime network
and the former live pd host dan abrams
is the founder
of this network now we're tracking
upcoming hearing
for the only police officer indicted in
the connection with a botched police
raid
which killed brianna taylor brett
hankinson is due for a pre-trial
conference
but there seems to be some confusion
among the court personnel
over whether it will occur in person or
via telephone
hankinson pleaded not guilty to three
counts of wanton endangerment
for shooting into neighboring apartments
during the raid
and finally a white teen from georgia
will serve four years in juvenile
detention
after saying she's sorry for carefully
planning
a knife attack on a historically black
church the team will serve an additional
10 years of probation after that four
years
prosecutors said the plot was racially
motivated it was foiled when classmates
found out
and told the school counselor thanks a
lot brian for those updates california
governor gavin newsom filing his own
court papers to call the death penalty
quote
infected by racism newsom made the
argument in a so-called friend of the
court brief in support of defendant
donte mcdaniel who is currently on death
row among the governor's arguments are
that not enough blacks are selected to
serve on juries
and their views are therefore not
reflected in sentencing
african-americans experiences have
shaped their views of the criminal
justice
and capital punishment systems newsome
wrote he also said
juries are disproportionately white and
death prone
heightening the risk that decisions will
be based
on racial bias those are the words of
the california governor so
brian i have to ask do you agree or
disagree with governor newsome
i agree to the heart of it maybe not the
wording specifically i do agree that
when we look at others and i'm not just
saying
looking at other people as you are
another person in this room but others
who don't fit in our same
group we tend to not view them in the
same light as those that we see in our
community and so sometimes those biases
even unconscious
can come forward in jury selection in
deciding whether or not someone's guilty
or innocent
or depending on sentencing one of the
most terrible things i think could
happen in america terry is that we would
feel as though we're being judged based
on
our race by a jury or something like
that you want to be judged based on what
you've done what you've said
the evidence in court you want to be
treated fairly and here the governor is
is putting his stamp on the criminal
justice system directly
by actually filing court paperwork it's
rather rare for governor to do that
it is you know i actually saw governor
newsom talk about this
very issue when i was in the audience
for a van jones show
and he is personally connected to this
issue he feels as though
he doesn't ever want to be part of
anyone getting sentenced to death he
feels as though defendants
have a right to be judged by a jury of
their peers and he's making this
argument that if in fact the black
population
is underrepresented and they're
disproportionately discarded
then they're not being represented by a
jury of their peers so this is something
that's close to his heart yes exactly
and he has put
his words right in the court record at
this point so there's no guessing about
where he stands on the issue
coming up after the break right here on
law and crime daily a baseball player
accused of using a bat to commit a
triple murder
we take you to the california courtroom
where that trial is unfolding
right after this
a former major league ball draft is on
trial for allegedly using a baseball bat
to beat three people to death inside a
california home
brandon willie martin faces three counts
of first-degree murder for the deaths of
his father michael martin
his uncle ricky anderson and repairman
barry swanson who just happened to be
there
prosecutors say in 2015 martin blew
through his
800 thousand dollars in earnings had no
jobs no friends and no prospects
they accused him of committing the
murders out of anger but his defense
says he was wrongly released
early after a mental health evaluation
and claims
the client is simply ill prosecutors are
going for the death penalty
he really was a man no prosper really
was somebody to be rejected
as attempted by reign rejected by his
family
and then he let his anger loose on those
closest he took that black
baseball bat engraved with his name
the name of his team and he struck out
at his family first he hit
ricky anderson you will find out
that ricky anderson died of multiple
block force injuries
inflicted by the defendant barry swanson
a man who truly was in the wrong place
at the wrong time
michael martin used to sit in a recliner
in the living room
and he sat in that chair and defended
face farther it was that black
baseball bat swung
with the force of a profession of a
professional baseball player
and crushed michael's craving
gruesome pictures in this case and
remember the defense opened with a
concession that the state's facts
are accurate but the defense said their
client's mental health was falling apart
and called out the state for releasing
him early from an institution
but you're going to see a picture emerge
of brandon martin
a picture that shows that between the
20th of 2015
his mind was changing because he
compensated
he was going through things that he
could not control his family worked
very hard to attempt to work with
and it came down on september 15
the family of which stands all along
but there is no question that mr brandon
martin scores
significant mental health issues that
were
addressed less than 48 hours later
he was cut loose sent on the street
here's a bus pass don't go home
and when we come back more from this
case involving drugs alcohol
and baseball bats surprising testimony
from the defendant's cousin and our
analysis
in the case against brandon willie
martin
[Music]
back now to the california trial of a
man charged with triple murder brandon
willie martin
short-lived professional baseball career
was marked by alleged cursing at coaches
failed drug tests
and a fractured thumb authorities say
they found a black baseball bat covered
in blood
etched into the bat was the defendant's
name his own cousin said the family
wanted to get him mental health care
but hesitated because they didn't want
to ruin his baseball career
he went from a nice presentable
person to
someone that you could tell there was
evil in his face in his eyes
i want to say the first time i noticed
it i was asked to come talk to him by
his mom
okay so melody asked you to go uh have a
discussion with brandon yes sir
and uh what do you know what year that
was
2015 i believe okay was it close in time
to the
instance that we're going to talk about
maybe within six months
when i saw him i didn't see
when i saw him at the house i didn't see
that
me talking to him would do any good
after looking at him
on cross the defendant's cousin said he
was the one who called police just
days before the attack but after the
family attempted some sort of
intervention
the goal was to have him arrested taken
away from
doing harm to the family and then work
on getting him help
and when you're discussing help you're
talking about
some sort of counseling is that right uh
actually i was looking into drug and
alcohol abuse treatment
when the police arrived brandon was
taken and placed on a 5150 hold
correct okay and you said earlier
that you knew what that was yes sir okay
what at that time what did a 5150 hold
mean to you
that it was taking him to a a hospital
for
mental like uh
to see if he was evaluating to see if
there's a mental issue
those fifty one fifty holds are
california's version of a mental health
hold
licensed psychologist and law and crime
expert dr john delator says the
defendant
could have been held past the 72-hour
window in that law
if he was considered a danger to himself
or others
the pterosaur act in california which
gave psychologists and
psychiatrists permission to break
confidentiality in either a duty to warn
or duty to protect
now for the most part the duty to warn
in california has kind of been
pushed to the side and everything's been
focused on duty to protect
here we have someone who has previously
interacted in a negative way against his
family so he has a target
right so we have as a psychologist a
duty to protect
so they should the family should have
been warned that he was going to be
released whether he was you know 48 or
the 72 hours
he the family should have been warned
and he should have been kept
inside the facility until they were for
sure
that he was no longer having those
thoughts and so for the defense
it sounds like he's kind of getting to
mental state at the time he committed
the offense but doesn't seem willing to
go the extra mile to actually get
a criminal responsibility evaluation
done so terry austin what do you make of
the mix between the defendant's mental
health status and the attempt by the
state
to have him convicted and executed here
you know aaron it's
clear that there's some mental illness
here you have witnesses testifying about
it you're going to have medical experts
who are testifying about it and dr
delatorre you know
stated that clearly the family should
have been
warned about this and for the
prosecution to seek the death penalty
which means obviously he'd be
executed here i think that is somewhat
unethical i think when you have it
clearly a defendant who has mental you
know illness
then you should be seeking something
less than the death penalty
of course there's a moratorium on it in
california but that may change under
another governor
brian got to ask the question about the
insanity defense the burden's on the
defense in california they follow the
mcnaughton rule that means the defendant
would basically have to prove he didn't
understand
the nature of his criminal act or that
he didn't understand it was morally
wrong but we had the cousin testify
that he saw evil in his face and eyes i
felt like that testimony was going right
straight
back at the defense tactic here yeah
it's interesting
even during the defense the the direct
sorry
that seemed to be very beneficial for
the defense i saw a deterioration of an
individual that went from something this
cousin could recognize
to something that he described as evil
and couldn't recognize
over the course of that time and being
close in time to the actual
death and incident that occurred plus
the mental health issues
would have been a slam dunk i thought it
played better for the prosecution but
that's just me hey we're out of time
here on long crime daily we'll see you
next time
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
[Music]
crime
[Music]
you